sécurité renforcée à tour pour la 17e
édition de la Marche des fiertés LGBTI
samedi le cortège à bénéficier d'une
protection supplémentaire de la part des
forces de l'ordre il faut dire que de
nouveaux slogans homophobes ont été
tagués dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi
sur le parcours que devait être
emprunter le cortège heureusement aucun
heure à signaler elle est à Turquie et à
la foule arc-en-ciel
une immense vague aux couleurs de
l'arc-en-ciel confettis paillettes
sourire et bienveillance la marge des
fiertés c'est une célébration et
certainement pas son musique
[Musique]
c'est important de manifester pour nos
droits etc c'est toujours convivial
c'est quand même important d'être
vraiment un bloc unique entre tout ça
quoi encourager la communauté LGBT en
globalité en fait ça rapidement en
France on est tous normaux 10 ans après
le mariage pour tous le combat continue
pour la communauté LGBTI plus une 17e
édition sous le soleil avec une
influence record pour la ville de Tours
5000 personnes selon les organisateurs
et 3000 selon la police on sera toujours
ensemble solidaire pour se défendre on
va continuer à lutter pour défendre nos
droits et pour et pour reconquérir de
nouveau pour que c'est un moment qui
permet de se retrouver entre nous d'être
bien et tout qui compense un peu la
difficulté que c'est d'être au quotidien
une marche symbolique après les
nombreuses attaques dont a été victime
le centre LGBTI de Touraine depuis le
début de l'année une manifestation donc
sous haute surveillance le double de
policiers vous voyez et même un drone
pour assurer la sécurité de toutes et
tous il y a un climat un petit peu
insécurisant surtout donc la préfecture
et la mairie m'a
beaucoup de manière positive et donc du
coup dire que c'est plutôt de très
rassurant de marquer autant de soutien
et qui ont mis plus de moyens aussi pour
pouvoir nous permettre de faire cet
événement une Pride d'ensemble militante
et sans accro qui vient clore de la
meilleure des manières la semaine des
fiertés
[Applaudissements]